[Music]
welcome to session number 15 this this
series on philosophers in the myths of
history we do one ancient philosopher in
spring and then we do a medieval
philosopher in the early late spring
early summer and then we do a modern
philosopher we're doing jean-jacques
Rousseau today in in late summer and
then finally in fall I guess you'd say
November right it's not yet winter we do
a contemporary or twentieth-century
thinker so we're doing jean-jacques
Rousseau and as we were talking about
before this he's a rather contradictory
fellow very fertile in in the things
that he wrote I don't think that you can
actually manage to fully integrate all
of his ideas together into one coherent
body of doctrine but that that's okay
because people have picked up on his
ideas and use them for so many things
that's part of what we're going to talk
about so in these talks and by the way I
encourage you at any time to ask
questions or you know if you've got
comments we can always come back to to
topic if there's anything that's unclear
but in these talks I always like to sort
of you know situate the philosopher in
his or her history in the sense of you
know the development of what's going on
where their life fits into the bigger
picture of what's happening but I also
talk about how they then come to
influence history because it's a it's a
back and forth it's very rare that you
have somebody who's just totally a
creature of their times and doesn't help
to shape their their times and sometimes
afterwards you know Rousseau hears a lot
of affect in his own time but he
probably has even more effect shortly
afterwards in the French Revolution so
what I thought we'd talk about first is
just the the context that that he is
growing up in and living in and working
in he's definitely a creature of the
18th century and we call that in English
the Enlightenment the French call it the
ciock the Lumiere which means the the
century of lights or of a luminary
illuminators and the germans call it the
elf clara
which also has this you know sense of
illuminating things and you know i
didn't put in on the timeline all the
different people who are doing
interesting enlightenment work at the
time but you know you can think about
all these figures some of whom don't
like Rousseau like Voltaire Voltaire is
from an older generation he and Rousseau
never get along although Rousseau likes
him quite a bit
Voltaire never liked so then you've got
people who are closer to him these
encyclopedias like Denis Diderot his
friend Dalembert believe it or not they
were also in this this sort of circle
with with one of the Grimm's and you
know there there were other people
engaging and important political ideas
like the Baron de Montesquieu you notice
that even you know one of the the big
texts that that made a lot of money for
its writers during that time it's a
little bit where's that yeah it's in
1732 Benjamin Franklin writes Poor
Richard's Almanack so it's not just the
European continent it's also you know
people are writing in America as well
there's a lot of back and forth
happening and so I thought we'd talk
about about that first and it's I think
it's impossible to talk about the
Enlightenment in general without noting
the the growing dominance of two
countries one is England England had
become a center of culture by the turn
of the 18th century as a matter of fact
somebody who doesn't you know managed to
get into that go tree - Vilhelm liveness
sort of the universal genius of of
Europe in Millay
seventeenth-century is very very sad
because he doesn't get to go to London
like the rest of the honover family
because he didn't do his job that they
hired him for which was he did all these
other things but he didn't he didn't
fulfill his obligations his family
historian so they left him behind when
they when they went to London but
liveness had gotten to go to Paris which
was the other major cultural centre and
in the 1800's Paris retains that status
and some of the other countries in the
18th century that were quite powerful at
the start and whose stars are sort of
waning would be like Spain for example
Sweden also Sweden had been a massive
power in the 17th century they played a
huge role in the Wars of Religion but
you know eventually they're there
they're not quite as important in the
East there's really three main powers
that are that are becoming important to
focus on one is Russia of course and
then there's Austria and then Prussia
and so you you're getting these these
nation states developing within Europe
and and you know nation-states they
require a lot of apparatus they need
working civil services they typically
have some sort of national culture that
they're trying to forward and to to some
degree control we're going to talk about
some of the controls on that in France
that affected Rousseau
so he's born into this context but he's
born in a different place he's born in
Switzerland and Switzerland is this kind
of you know thorny little upstart
mountain locked kingdom of a whole bunch
of different fairly independent Canton's
each of which is kind of doing its own
thing one that one of which is actually
involved with Prussia at the
those we're gonna talk about and being
born there and being born particularly
in Geneva which is in the
french-speaking part of Switzerland
Rousseau is getting a very different
upbringing than say somebody who'd been
born into France or Prussia or England
and that's going to color his views and
it's also gonna open up possibilities
for him that that might not have existed
for others there's a lot of wars going
on here and there is these these powers
spar with each other there's this
continual emphasis on sort of
centralizing power generally against the
nobility who don't like that sort of
thing
in France they actually distinguish
between two kinds of nobility the know
the know blessed and that Bay which
means that the nobles of the sword you
know the old warrior types who hold land
from from their feudal conquests and
then the know blessed of the little hope
which means the nobles of the gown and
why would they wear a gown well they
were you know somebody in the Civil
Administration
so it's possible for the rising
bourgeoisie to become part of the the
state apparatus of power and to start
affecting policy and changing the
culture and you know the aristocrats
didn't really like that so you have this
constant back and forth in the 18th
century between these kings and there
there's you know civil services and
oftentimes the bourgeoisie lining up
with them until the Kings spend too much
money and then the nobles and then
you've got the church as well involved
and there's a lot of entanglements there
not just between the church and the
state but also given the fact that some
of these Nobles are holding their titles
from you know religious endowments as
well you could if you find all these
people who are the abbot at the abbey in
French or the abbot in English of such
in such a place and they never go there
they're just drunk this is drawing the
rents from it and living at court and do
their thing and I suppose the other
thing to say politically to that's
that's quite important is louis xiv
who's you know pretty much gone by the
time verso is you know a kid louis xiv
managed to really centralize power in in
France and to defang the nobility in
part by requiring them to be at court
and and he reigned for a very long time
too
so when you've got that kind of power
for that sort of time you can really
start to change a not just a culture but
but the politics of what's going on a
few other things that are happening that
before we get into the intellectual
scene trade is is you know booming all
over the place as a matter of fact some
of the wars that they're having are over
trade so you've got not only these these
massive nation-states but but also
mercantile powers you could think of
like the the Dutch for example or the
Portuguese who are gonna play a role
until they can you know get shuffled off
the scene and they're getting to know
the world far better you know you could
think of the seventh the the 17th
century as an era of exploration lots of
exploration going out of South America
North America and you know parts of
Africa all sorts of trade things
established with the East Indies with
China with India and and that sort of
thing is getting consolidated by by the
18th century people know where things
are on the map except for you know if
it's really deep in the heart of you
know South America or Africa
maybe they they haven't penetrated that
far but for the most part they know
where things are now it's a question of
how do you get the commodities from
there to here reliably without you know
piracy taking it over or your rival
mercantile powers taking it so they're
all jarring with each other over that
and and they're getting to know not just
about the cultures of these people but
about their ways of life and their modes
of thought so you know just for an
example
the Catholic Church the Pope was was the
one who ended up deciding this they had
to decide that that Christianity and
Confucianism were indeed not compatible
with each other because when the Jesuits
went into China the Jesuits were you
know translating the Bible and Christian
writings into into Chinese and so
they're trying to find concepts that
would work so you know God becomes t on
or heaven which is not quite the same
thing as the guy out of the Bible and
you know the Jesuits always were a
little fast and loose with that sort of
thing during missionary work and
eventually I mean a word gets back
basically from the Franciscans who are
like these Jesuits you know look at them
what they're doing and they get
condemned
I may get told get to get out of China
you know you're no longer allowed
quickness and in more reliable people
but why are they why are they doing that
because they need to make sense out of
the fact that within China you have this
massive body of thought that really does
seem to make sense and it offers a way
to understand you know the human beings
and their hierarchies and the divine and
everything else and so that's part of
what's going on in the 18th century is
this confrontation with other ways of
looking at things and that's very
liberating because you know if you only
have one way of seeing things and it
seems to make sense
you know you might tinker around with it
a bit right you might say well this part
doesn't really seem to work anymore work
great in the 12th century but doesn't
work great in the 18th century but
you're probably not going to radically
revised it right but when you when you
have other models you can be like well
why is our model the correct one maybe
we should you know really think think
about this stuff and so you see for
example Montesquieu writing the Persian
letters you know it was it was kind of 8
& Voltaire does this sort of thing - it
was quite popular to say hey I met this
this guy from this land here and they do
things differently isn't it weird how we
do things this way maybe we don't have
to do things this way anymore
which is a you know a rather progressive
way of you know attacking traditional
structures and beliefs and things like
that and so that that was quite a common
thing that they would do in the
Enlightenment there's you know we're
talking about intellectual life so and
it is it is something that belongs to an
elite it's not the ordinary person on
the street who is really engaging in
this although literacy is becoming you
know more and more common and and more
and more books are being printed and
more and more broad sheets are being
printed as well you can just you know
tack up to a wall and have people read
sort of like you know we've got you know
Twitter and message boards and stuff
like that that's what a broadsheet it
essentially was back then you'd go to
the tavern or coffee house and you'd
have your your big almost like a poster
saying the mayor sucks you know here's
why he's a terrible guy and he spent the
money on this event or you know it could
be this book is great or we should think
about this idea and people would
communicate with each other that way so
even though ordinary people could get
involved with it but they weren't they
weren't the drivers of the Enlightenment
you know the Enlightenment is still
being driven by an elite but it's no
longer an elite of nobility and it's no
longer an elite as it was in Western
Europe of an educated clergy because you
know if you think about who the elite
were who were you know driving culture
in the Middle Ages it was mostly the
clergy now it's it's a secular people
who might be philosophers or they might
you know build themselves as geometers
or
might build themselves in all sorts of
other ways pop you know political
thinkers but they're there they're
engaging with each other and engaging
with ideas and proposing new ways to
think of things and from the perspective
of anybody who is you know sort of
rather traditional at the time which
could it could be everybody from those
wanting to maintain political
institutions the same to those who are
concerned about the Guild's going under
to those who are worried about things
for religious reasons all of this
enlightenment the activity is kind of
dangerous
it's undermining people's long-held
views it's calling things into question
right so Rousseau is going to be part of
that but as we were talking about at the
beginning he's not an Enlightenment
figure in the same way that some of
these other people are like if you
contrast them to Voltaire for example
you know Voltaire tends to look at
things in terms of a fairly
straightforward account of human
progress and Rousseau it's a lot it's a
lot murkier you know there's there's a
lot of ways in which progress is bad for
us as we'll talk about but but on the
other hand you know we can't just stay
rooted in the past that we've had and or
just you know maintain a static present
so the you know part of what they're
they're trying to figure out in the
Enlightenment is is really a couple big
questions one is what is human nature
what is it that that how do we
understand human beings what is it that
makes us what we are do we need to look
to the Bible for an account of that or
religious authorities for an account of
that or do we take a different attitude
that's the less beholden to those I mean
they'll still talk about God a lot but
but it's kind of a abstract God instead
or and it's sort of a deist watchmaker's
God they're really interested in well
how do we develop and
noticed that was so if you look at some
of his texts is talking about how human
beings evolved he doesn't use the word
evolution which is more of a 19th
century thing but he's talking about
that he's not talking about necessarily
genetic evolution he's talking about how
do we as a species become more and more
complex and more and more distant from
our origins and whether we're developing
in the right way as well that's another
key issue for him and he's not the he's
not the only person so you've got these
accounts that people are providing
talking about you know criminal states
of nature some of this goes back quite a
ways to like you know Thomas Hobbes in
the city in the 17th century but now
they're starting to use the
anthropological materials that they've
got they can do cross comparisons they
don't have to speculate about the Native
Americans they've got you know a hundred
years of people writing about them
oftentimes you know from biased
perspectives but but better than what
Hobbes had to work on and better than
what John Locke had to work on and
they've also got these accounts of what
people do in China or India or in other
places so they can use that for for
doing sort of cross cross comparative
studies the other thing that they're
really really centered on is the the
question of society who should be
running things and how should they be
run and you could say that you know I
don't know if you can say that feudalism
ever really worked that level that
effectively in Europe it worked good at
the time I guess better than some of the
other well you know everything every
political system works great for
somebody Hegel has this this great quip
and I think it's in the philosophy of
history where he says he's contrasting
the sort of what he calls the Asian
spirit and the Greek spirit and the
Christian spirit he says with Asian
spirit and of course he's generalizing
here only one man can be
the guy at the top right and then for
the Greeks a few can be free the ones
who are at the top as well and aren't
slaves or non-citizens or something like
that and then under Christianity
everybody can be free you know so he
sees this this kind of evolution
obviously that's an idealization but you
can say that one of the things in the
Enlightenment thinkers were really
interested in is that movement how do
you go from a few people being the ones
who are free in the sense that they can
enjoy life and decide with what kind of
life they're gonna have and get to
participate in political deliberations
and determinations how do you go from
just a few to to many without everything
falling apart because I mean you know
you could imagine these guys looking
around the populous and saying you know
we want that guy to vote I don't know
about that you know how do you how do
you do that well one way is by changing
the nature of the people that you've got
to work with so if you can you know
remove prejudices and superstitions and
get rid of government corruption and you
see where this is going right this is
the same thing that we say today if we
could just like get people to see
clearly where their true interests lie
then you know our politics wouldn't be
so toxic if people just weren't so
prejudiced and rooted in their ways
whether I'm left or right or even in the
center we could all get along and figure
out what to do about a global climate
change or the threat that China is
posing or you know what we're gonna do
when when AI and robotics takes all of
our jobs or you know any of these sorts
of things that we are our political
system is clearly incapable of actually
handling right so I mean the
Enlightenment figures you can see where
they're coming from they didn't have you
know 300 years of people trying to do
that and it not working out like we do
or you can say in the present yeah I
mean this they tried this they tried the
French Revolution
and that didn't really work out as
planned you know our American Revolution
culminated in a political system that it
meant in some respects is really great
at the time but now is sort of like a
Model T Ford where we're constantly
replacing very old parts that don't seem
to work very good and people are zooming
past us in their you know modern modern
Ford's or Alexis's you know they they
didn't have that they they could
actually dream of like well what if we
actually did in fact remove the scales
from everybody's eyes and they saw for
the first time that the right thing to
do is to say maximize the positive
outcomes for everybody and minimize the
harms wouldn't that be amazing you know
and so there there are a lot of thinkers
who propose things like that and and
along with that goes that you know sort
of a critique of religious institutions
and arbitrary political institutions
like you know why do we have to have a
king you know does that seem to be the
most effective way of governing to have
this hereditary monarchy now saying
stuff like that could get you thrown in
jail right and some of these guys did
quite frankly but it you know you can
see that it it's it's creating an
environment in which Rousseau's thought
can can flourish and we can say that the
18th century after the death of her so
you know it really culminates in in one
massive event which is not the American
Revolution it's the French Revolution
because because France was a more
important country at the time really at
the center of the West and it turns
everything topsy-turvy it creates this
animosity of all the other powers
against France generates what would we
say like two decades of like constant
war and also creates some breathing
space for our project over here you know
I don't know that the war of 1812 would
have gone quite so I mean it didn't go
well for us
but I think it could have gone way worse
if the British you know weren't fighting
the French at the time so you know the
French Revolution is quite important so
Rousseau let's talk about Russo's life
and I created this timeline for you to
give you some of the high notes so he's
born in Geneva and he's a citizen of
Geneva and that's that's important
because it means that you know as
opposed to like being born in France he
would have been subject to the king of
France he's subject to the you know much
smaller state of Geneva his mom dies
shortly after childbirth and his father
Isaac and there was a bit of a disparity
there - his mother is from sort of you
know the upper-class his father's a
craftsman and his father brings in his
sister to help raise the boys doesn't
take too long before they relocate and
they end up living in this craftsman
neighborhood and we're so get some of
his ideas about you know the value of
handle work as opposed to being you know
an aristocrat from from that and that's
kind of important for for him I think
I'm well quite a few of these
enlightenment types could be you know
rather abstract about that sort of thing
Rousseau actually knew what it was like
for people to work and and another thing
that was really cool that his father did
now his father's kind of a you know good
guy bad guy sort of figure but one of
the good things that he did is he had
all these books that were I think
essentially the property of his dead
wife and he starts reading these with
young Jean Jacques and teaching him how
to read and then they read the books
together and they discuss them and
that's part of how Rousseau ends up
getting like you know the first
beginnings of his education he and the
confessions and unfortunately you know
we want to talk about an unreliable
narrator you really can't trust
everything there it's so says in his
confessions right
and that's one of the main sources we
have for his life is his autobiography
but he says that you know he read all
these these you know novels and fantasy
works and he's you know modeling himself
after people and Plutarch's lives you
know so if you think about the reading
if we were on our own and we didn't have
elementary school or middle school and
we just had a bunch of books and a dad
who is actually willing to read them
with us and talk with us about them
that's probably a pretty decent
education right I mean we could have
gone much worse imagine if it was all
just you know Army field manuals or
romance novels you know mercenary now
hosts or something like that now
eventually his his dad gets into a
conflict with a land over overhunting
and he has to get out of town
he and his sister moved to kneel and
they leave jean-jacques behind with with
his uncle and his uncle houses him with
a Calvinist minister just outside of
town really a strict guy eventually
jean-jacques gets apprenticed to a
notary then to an engraver the engraver
beats him so he's you know he's learning
quite a few things his craft beatings
are awful and he runs away from Geneva
to to Savoy and there he meets this
Catholic priest who introduces him to
one of the first important women in his
life Francois who has
Warren and she is a what would you call
her she's sort of like a religious
headhunter she's she's out there looking
for conversions she was originally a
Protestant and so she would travel
around and and you know sort of like you
know she'd give you the the the you know
the soft shoe this is where they could
salt the soft-pedal you know approach my
Catholicism is so great you should
convert back and she and Russo are going
to become involved
but before that she actually converts
and he gets disowned immediately by his
family then he becomes eventually the
lover of the warran and he starts
studying philosophy and mathematics and
music and he's actually quite good when
it comes to music he writes a
dissertation on modern music eventually
he receives a small inheritance and then
partially repays de Warren for her
support and he's becoming independent
now he becomes a tutor in the yawl in
1739 1742 he moves to Paris and he's got
a new idea for musical notation and he
presents it to the Academy to see anse
they say no this is this is very smart
but it's not gonna work and he was
hoping he'd actually make his fortune
with this but he being in Paris he meets
this guy Denis Diderot and Diderot is
one of these enlightenment intellectuals
Diderot is going to be involved with
this massive project called the
encyclopedia that we'll come back to in
just a bit
encyclopedias I'll just say this by side
no I mean did anything grow up with a
world book in your family or an
encyclopedia britannica or something
like that i used to read them all the
time when i was a kid you know just open
up to an entry and read about it it was
it was really cool you know the overlays
like in the coalmine you can see where
the coal comes from or you know I'll
tell you a funny story too so when I was
a kid I started reading pretty girly I
said I learned to read when I was 3 and
then I just started reading stuff and
sometimes I wouldn't associate the words
that I knew I guess you'd say orally
right with the words that I was reading
on the page so I came downstairs one
time and I was telling my mom I'd been
reading an entry on dolphins and I was
telling her about there's still much 'iz
and you know what went on with this
organ I didn't make the Association
that's a stomach I was pronouncing it
you know the way it seemed it should be
pronounced so much right
because that's why it's written and my
mom's like what the hell are you talking
about what's this so much and so I
pointed it on the page and she and then
by the time I pointed it I realized what
it where things had gone wrong you know
but you know it's a sign of how you know
how much we took the world book for for
granted you know so we'll come back to
the to that in a bit
he also then becomes the secretary to
this ambassador to Venice and so that
gets him to Venice which is quite
interesting get some you know to see
what's going on that unfortunately the
guy the Ambassador typically wasn't paid
for his own work for more than a year
after he did it and there was a
trickle-down effect he doesn't get paid
his servants don't get paid so Rousseau
wasn't getting paid either I mean so you
know after waiting a year to get paid
this it was like that I'm not doing this
anymore
so he he comes back to Paris then he
becomes involved with this this woman
Therese Lev a sewer who's a she's a
servant woman and but clearly he was
quite taken with her because he got her
pregnant five times over the course of
his life every single time he and her
mother convinced her to give the the
children up to what was called at that
time a foundling hospital which really
means an orphanage and there's a lot of
dispute about this there's there some
people who say well that's basically
given the infant mortality of the time
and the way these things were run that
was basically like you know the death
sentence for the kid you know if they
survive they're probably pretty lucky he
never did ten years later he wanted to
find his son he wasn't particularly
interested in daughters then he couldn't
he couldn't track anything down nobody
knew anything but he was you know he was
quite taken with her he she will play an
important role later on around that time
he he writes a letter introducing
himself to Voltaire
and Voltaire you know doesn't doesn't
give him much of a response shortly
after that in 1749 he wins a big prize
that kind of puts him on the map he
writes the discourse on the sciences and
the arts to fulfill this this prize
contest for the Academy - Dijon and
that's the first of his discourses and
that's where he's sort of laying out
some of his ideas about human
development and and politics and how the
different activities that we do like the
arts change our nature over time and
change the structure of society
meanwhile I should probably start
talking about some of the things on the
other side you know around this time
Montesquieu is publishing the spirit of
the laws
Diderot gets jailed for a while under
what's called the letter to cash a
meaning hide him away and Diderot and
Dalembert shortly after we so is
publishing this discourse on the
sciences and the arts
they begin publishing their encyclopedia
they had they had written a prospectus
for it about five years before that
trying to raise money and the whole idea
with the encyclopedia so now now let's
talk about the encyclopedia we think of
it encyclopedia as well
you know it's this set of books you buy
them maybe you buy it on installments
you know a hundred bucks a month or
something like that they're in houses
there's some in the library over here
right you got you know the world book
for for kids you know later on you look
at the Britannica or the Americana or
what are some of the other big ones and
then there's you know encyclopedias
online that you can buy or Bioman cd-rom
but it was it was really a revolutionary
thing at the time and Voltaire earlier
had actually written a or is that later
on no later on he writes a philosophical
dictionary right in dictionaries or
writing encyclopedias at that time was a
subversive act because it's not just
that you're making knowledge available
to people you get to write how you get
to write the articles how you want them
and you decide what goes into it what
counts what what needs to be in there so
imagine if you write an article on
monarchy and you say well there are many
different you know the kinds of
monarchies and and then you include a
paragraph on some people think that
monarchy actually is not that good and
probably should be replaced with
something else you know or you start
writing on religious topics and you say
you know you didn't have to like come
straight out you say some people have
the idea that all these miracles that
the Saints are supposed to have done
those are just natural occurrences not
saying I endorse that but you know some
people think this is reasonable and
here's the arguments that they use to
explain this right so the way that you
do you can also of course be very you
know just report there are no miracles
you know Pierre Bayle was it was a
person who wrote encyclopedia entries
and he would he would say stuff like
that in an earlier time so putting
together an encyclopedia like this is a
big deal it's a lot of work right but
it's also something that makes it
possible for people to have a common
vocabulary and imagine a different a
different world and discuss it with each
other it provides a basis so Rousseau
will write some entries for for the
encyclopedia so will a whole bunch of
other people as well coming back to
Rousseau he writes a comedy called
narcissus or the self admirer which in
some ways could be you know the disguise
of the autobiographical right because I
think he's a little bit narcissistic and
then he composes an opera now this is a
really kind of curious thing so his
opera gets performed for the King Louis
the 15th who
sometimes called Louie the beloved
people liked Louie the 15th things were
you know there were a lot of things that
were screwed up in his reign but for the
most part the people tended to like him
the first part of his reign actually
there were two sort of competing figures
because he's crowned king when he's five
years old so obviously you can't rule
the duke of or early on is the regent
for a while and then you've got this guy
the cardinal de Fleury who becomes quite
important as well and anyway the you
know being having a thing performed for
the king well that'd be like having your
opera performed for the president all
right and then the King offers him a
pension basically saying I'll set you up
for life you can just you know do your
thing and you're obviously very talented
and Rousseau refuses he turns it down
and everyone's like what the hell is
wrong with you you know and it was
partly because he wanted to maintain
independence and eventually he's going
to return to Geneva and and it becomes a
Calvinist again and then he in 1755
there's two important discourses that
come up one of which he writes for
another prize competition doesn't win it
that's the discourse on the origin and
basis of inequality among men that's
what I typically teach in which these
handouts are are drawn from and then the
discourse on political economy he gets
involved with another woman the Madame
de d'Epinay who's who's fascinated with
him she has a cottage you know set up
for him that he calls The Hermitage out
in the countryside and then he falls in
love with this woman the Sophie do notes
and that leads to a quarrel with with
Madame d'epinay and Diderot and Grimm
about you know what's going on Rousseau
is a person who gets into quite a few
conflicts of that sort
and eventually he leaves and he starts
you know traveling around again then he
writes Julie or the new Eloise and that
one you know his other things that made
him some some money make some money
printing things out Julie made a lot of
money for him as did a meal or on
education as well which comes out the
next year as well as what's considered
to be one of his most important
political works of the social contract
and we're going to talk about one of the
key ideas from that that in part leads
to the french revolution and also gets
Rousseau vilified as a proto-fascist
later on called the general will now
around this time there there's going to
be more crackdowns and the Encyclopaedia
the the permission to publish it is
revoked they continue publishing it in
secret they claim that it's being
published in Switzerland when it's
actually being published in France
because in Switzerland the threat the
French you know Parliament and King and
clergy can't touch you but in you know
if you're publishing it in France then
you can get in a lot of trouble
meanwhile the the Parlement of Paris and
the Parliament is is the nobles right
the Parliament condemns Rousseau's book
and meal and they make out a warrant for
his arrest
Volterra actually offers him refuge but
Rousseau doesn't take in his offer up he
flees to Baron in Switzerland and then
after the Baron waz tell him you need to
get the hell out of here we don't want
you here
he goes to noise Chatel which at that
time I'd mentioned there was a
connection between Prussia and
Switzerland so noise should tell is
actually ruled by Frederick the Great at
that time there were there are quite a
few little patchwork things all over
Europe where like this this monarch
would have liked this little province
here and so the fact that it's it's
ruled by
frederik means that russo can get some
refuge there he eventually relocates to
this other place that yield a sump here
than to Strasbourg and then he goes to
England and in England he he was going
at the the the invitation of David Hume
who's a very important philosopher today
less known for philosophy at that time
more known for his historical work and
for his literary and artistic criticism
and and he's tied into the whole bunch
of intellectuals you know and through
that you know Rousseau is reunited with
with tourette's and then eventually he
gets into a dispute with Hume and to get
into a dispute with Hume you got to
really be a jerk because Hume was a
really really easygoing guy you you you
know we've all got like friends who'll
put up with just about anything and you
know they always look on the better side
right
well that's Hume and and Rousseau you
know managed to even get on Humes nerves
and he also starts writing the
confessions at that time and and
Rousseau is a big enough name that Hume
is actually quite worried that he's
going to show up in the confessions
which is gonna be a tell-all you know
and that it'll make him look bad so
there's that that whole affair going on
he goes back to France under an assumed
name and begins suffering from some
severe paranoia and anxiety starts
moving around sometimes with tourists
sometimes not eventually he marries her
but he marries her under a false name so
it's an invalid ceremony he finishes his
confessions in 1769 but he doesn't
publish them at that time
as a matter of fact they're not going to
published during his lifetime what he
does with them is he goes around and
does public readings sort of like you
know we we have that at bookstores today
right an author will come in and they go
to Boswell's
you know you drive downtown and and well
Upper East Side right and you go there
and and they're sitting there and
they've got their chair and you know
they read a chapter or something and
they got their books for sale in the
back and then you know people come up
and they say ha you're so wonderful and
you know or you know what were you doing
in this chapter or they they asked you
know the really questions that they
think nobody's ever asked where do you
get your ideas from right and Mme author
you know gets out of there after about
an hour and a half after selling ten
books or something so every Souls
readings were not like that it was quite
common back then to have readings of
books and one person who recounts
Rousseau's confessions readings but I'm
laughing is that thinking about this he
says you know I was used to like going
in and listening to a reading for six
hours or so this was fourteen hours and
and then here's the kicker you know it
was very long but but it was really such
a wonderful work that the time just flew
by can you imagine sitting there for 14
hours listening to this guy reeve his
book and recount his life and tell you
his thoughts on things
Minoo I have a hard time picturing that
I don't you know I've had days where I
had to teach nine hours
we're had you know lecture and discuss
things for for nine hours during the day
and by the end of that day my vocal
cords you know because whoa cool chords
are really muscles they would be sore
and swollen and I could barely speak at
all it's like when a person has
laryngitis and I I'd be like drinking
tea and you know using Ricola all day
long - as well I can't picture doing
that for 14 hours you know and he did
that four times the thing that brings it
to an end is the Madame Madame de
d'Epinay who figures as a character in
there Suze because she doesn't like
we're so airing her dirty laundry
these public readings so that puts the
end to that and he you know he gets
involved in a few more political
writings a constitutional project for
Corsica considerations on the government
of Poland in 1776 you know the year of
our our revolution which really begins
in 1755 but you know gets gets gets
really going he he gets injured he gets
knocked down by this Great Dane there's
actually like a carriage coming and a
Great Dane and to get out of the way of
the carriage he gets in the way of the
Great Dane and it knocks him down and he
has a concussion and people who read
about it think that he probably had
neurological damage as well because
there were there are some other things
going on after that he's gonna die two
years later of cerebral bleeding after a
stroke so that probably factored into
that he was never really you know up to
things after that but you notice that
some of those things are getting
published later so the essay on the
origin of languages another really
important work when you put it together
with these other discourses because it
fits into his picture of how human
beings develop and then the confessions
finally gets published as well as
dialogues Rousseau judge of jean-jacques
which is not just an autobiography but a
vindication right he's saying I get to
be the judge of myself and then reveries
of a solitary Walker is another one of
his works as well and so you know not
too long after that 1789 so seven years
after confessions are published eleven
years after Rousseau is is dead the
French Revolution begins and the French
Revolution is going to draw on some of
Rousseau's key ideas and as we were
talking about before
not in a coherent way not not like they
you know had a you know Oliver Soze
books together in one volume and they're
like you've got to read this stuff it's
more like we like this idea from
Rousseau the rest of it forget about it
well
we'll figure that out as we go along
because you know the French Revolution
is it's not just like one one thing it's
all these different people that
cross-purposes and and you know some of
them guillotine each other for not being
radical enough and then some of them get
guillotine for not being radical enough
and and it leads them to a terror
eventually you know there's they have to
restore order and Napoleon comes out on
top after quite a lot of mess so before
we go into some of his key ideas I've
talked quite a while at you and any
questions or comments or clarifications
or concerns no so I want to be mindful
of our time too so I'll just tell you
about a few of the big ideas
one is that Rousseau thinks that as I
mentioned human beings evolve we we
start out in a state of nature but we're
not in a state of nature and when we do
these imaginations of well what would it
be like if we took away society like we
do in some movies or some TV shows you
know these zombie shows that have been
around for an hour like 10 years like
Walking Dead you know we have a there's
a terrible thing that happens what would
human beings be like if the electricity
failed and we're back in a brutal
condition what's that yeah Lord of the
Flies is an imagination although those
are kids you know and in a way Lord of
the Flies is sort of like sticking it to
the people who are like yeah kids are
innocent they they they're all nice
they're logical everything yeah so
Russo's view is that in our natural
state we're not really we're not bad
like that as a matter of fact we're not
even very developed we don't have
language we don't have fixed habitation
it takes a while for families to even
evolve we do have a sort of primitive
sense of sympathy when we see a wounded
member of our own species you see this
with other animals too though you know
like water buffaloes will come and get
the water buffalo that the
rocket aisle hands and step on the
crocodiles head or go after the the lion
that's you know got one of those
wildebeests or things like that and as
we start to develop we get more and more
complex and we get further away from the
primitive whether he calls them savages
they're the beginning State for human
beings is savagery and so think about
like doesn't really you know unorganized
hunter-gatherer groups and then we we
start to because of developing certain
technologies which include language but
also include agriculture and metallurgy
and social organization we begin to
develop and evolve as as a species and
again not in terms of our genetics in
terms of our culture I mean physically
we're not as we're not as Hardy and
we're not as you know pain resistant as
primitive people are but that's just
because we grew up soft right and so as
things start to get more and more
complex we get into a state that he
calls barbarism and in barbarism we have
like almost the full panoply of human
emotions developed that weren't there
originally we start to measure ourselves
against each other an awful lot we start
to become very insistent on our rights
and enforcing them through justice
largely through revenge scaring off
other people from messing with us we get
very interested in where we fit into the
social hierarchy we don't yet have a
very well-developed political system and
laws it's sort of up to you know
whoever's got the power to enforce this
on others and we start to lose some of
that primitive sense of compassion or
sympathy you know it becomes much more
selective we care about those who are
close to us and screw everybody else
right that's the way he depicts human
beings that's actually probably Rousseau
gets pictured as if he thinks that
savagery is the
thing but I think he really thinks
barbarism is actually better in many
respects because you got more going on
and and it's a lot more interesting then
we get civilization and and most
thinkers you know frame civilization is
a really good thing right
we're soul thinks it's a catastrophe but
a necessary catastrophe that has to
develop out of this because you know
when you live in a situation of
barbarism people screw each other over
and sooner or later people are like this
you know things are too unreliable we
need to have some order here who can
produce some order and then Rousseau
says he's got a couple different you
know like narrative stories for how this
happens but one of them is the rich
hoodwink the poor by saying we're gonna
have a social contract and in this
contract
everybody's gonna keep their hands off
of everybody else's stuff and they'll be
like an authority to enforce this we'll
call them the magistrate will give them
power and say you know you can find
people or kill them or put them in jail
or you know do stuff make them labor if
they if they won't keep their hands off
other people's stuff or if they kill
other people or they do other things
that they're not supposed to do and you
know we'll elect some people to do this
and and so they they pick people
originally on the basis of what Rousseau
calls virtue and you know virtue means
like moral goodness so you know when you
put together your Fantasy Island let's
call it you pick the person who you
think is the most reliable or the most
just what else would we want them to
have you know incorruptible right and
you establish them now Rousseau is very
realistic at least about this it's not
going to stay that way for very long
because there's other ways that we
distinguish ourselves against each other
that are going to inevitably start to
dominate so originally it could be like
you know the virtuous versus the the
vicious or the non virtuous let the
virtuous be in charge the vicious should
should obey but it starts to become a
matter of rich and poor or powerful and
we
or those who have high social status and
those who have low social status and as
it turns out if you got enough money you
can buy yourself power you can buy
yourself social status right yeah and if
you're poor you're kind of screwed you
know or if you're if you're strong you
can use that to get yourself more social
status or to get yourself you know rich
and strong politically right getting
getting to be in power and so new elites
come to be and these elites are
generally based not on virtue but on all
these other things so the rich you know
come to think that they deserve to rule
and that society makes perfect sense
and Rousseau identifies the key
characteristic of human beings that
other people have pointed out to that I
think is quite true and in many respects
he says why would somebody accept being
in a lower position in the hierarchy I
mean it's just they don't have the guts
to stand up for themselves what would be
the motive that would justify being like
in a middle position having to shine
somebody else's boots you know put up
with their put up with a noble person or
the rich person's nonsense what would it
be it's not just being cowardly so
security that that's one thing that's
not the one thing that he points out
though maybe you're all too good you
know to relate to this you get to kick
the person who's below you so long as
you're not at the bottom of the
hierarchy you're okay being at that
middle part because you get to lord it
over that poor bastard down there you
know now the guy on the very bottom okay
he doesn't I guess he can you know kick
the the cockroach or something like that
but Rousseau thinks that this is this is
what society becomes and civilization
becomes more and more corrupting and so
if you have that point of view then
really the best thing to do is to get
away from the corrupting influences of
civilization but that's kind of a you
know it's kind of a tough thing to do
because civilization all
so means all these things that we like
right like you know being relatively
clean and you think about our day if
somebody was to say to you
this civilization that we live in this
is this is all degenerate and corrupt we
should get the hell away from this I
bought an island where we can all live
in savagery you know you're gonna have
to leave your cell phone behind what
else would we have to you know you're
gonna live in these huts and you're
gonna catch fish with Spears and it's
gonna be a good life you know we've got
fire we've got metal and if you have any
problems with the guy next to you well
you know beat him up and if he has
problems with you he'll beat you up so
you'll all be nice to each other or or
you won't I think a lot of us would be
like you know we might feel like yeah
that sounds great and we're there for a
weekend and then we're like oh man I got
to get back to civilization
and and you know this Rousseau Ian motif
this goes through all the way into the
1960s because people like the hippies
read Rousseau and they're like yeah we
should get back to this sort of thing
this isn't actually be quite good you
know yeah and you know within a calm you
know how do you settle disputes well you
know you can have like everybody get
together and vote or you could have
people punch each other in the nose you
know and settle things that way it's not
nonviolent but you know it does
hopefully put an end to things
another issue that he was really
concerned with was I mentioned the
general will so Rousseau thinks that
there's different kinds of freedom
there's you know the freedom that we
have in the state of nature you can do
anything you like
but there's almost nothing to do other
than eat and drink and sleep and try not
to get eaten by something else and then
there's the freedom that you have is a
creature who has become intelligent
enough to give him or herself rules to
live by and impose those rules upon
yourself and that's kind of sort of
leading in the direction of eventually a
manual conte and this notion of autonomy
then we have
civil or political freedom as well and
that you know involves our rights to do
certain things but those can be crimped
by something that he calls the general
will and the general will is not as he
says the will of everybody all put
together like if we vote you know in a
democracy
so none of our presidents have really
been elected by the general will instead
it's it's this sort of much more you
could say substantive notion of
something that would really it would be
a will it would be something that makes
rules makes decisions for the good of
the totality and so it's not just you
know this group who's in who's got you
know 51% decides things it's supposed to
be more of a consensus and here's where
you know that sounds pretty good but
here's where it gets a little bit
dangerous Rousseau says that sometimes
you have to be forced to be free and
what that means is you know generally
all of us are because we have you know
we're self-centered we're gonna be not
in full accordance with the general will
some of us will actually be out of
accordance with the general will if we
were really being rational we would see
that the best thing for us is to be in
accordance with the general will and the
general will should take priority over
our own selfish interests so given that
when we're being crushed beneath the
general well because we don't want to do
it it wants us to do through its
representatives were just being forced
to be free we're just being forced to
actually live up to the the rational
requirements of what it means to be a
human being in a society now I think you
can see very quickly where this can be
abused if I'm in charge and I'm the
magistrate I represent the general will
so what if you got on my bad side
because we had a personality conflict
might be tempting for me to say you know
those people they're they
they may talk a good game but they're
really not in the coordinates with the
general will guillotine them you know or
certain classes of people you know oh
you know those those peasants this
happened a lot in the French Revolution
there really you know quite backwards
they still believe in in in you know the
Christian religion not in the proper
deism or atheism of the religion of the
revolution they don't want to let their
kids go to public school because they
say they have to be out in the fields
that's guillotine amore we don't another
popular way of killing people in the
countryside was let's put them on barges
chain them to the barges and then sink
the barges there's a lot if people have
actually talked about trying to view
this I don't think it's all that
plausible but you know there's an
argument there as a type of genocide
that was carried out during the French
Revolution against people in in the
country and so this this notion of the
general will in the hands of somebody
like Robespierre it could become a very
dangerous idea and that is that is
indeed what happened to it Rousseau
didn't think that his that's one of the
big problems isn't that I mean
practically speaking you know what you
know so the only people that are going
to talk in terms of the general will are
pretty much the revolutionaries who are
influenced by Rousseau you're not going
to see the nobility or the the king or
any of the people who are who are
against the revolution talking about the
general will and then they're gonna
argue amongst themselves about what the
general will really requires and you
know Rousseau pictures it is like this
kind of hashing out process involving
argument and dialogue between the
citizens although you do have you know
the manager
who's supposed to be enforcing the
general will and sometimes they'd have
to act once once you've got like a
crisis mentality you know I mean if you
think about what happens in the French
Revolution so they you know in the early
stages they take over Paris they start
you know imprisoning sometimes beating
sometimes killing the nobles some of the
clergy people who are viewed as being in
line with them and then they're the the
reaction of the outside world is we got
to crush this you know this this has got
to end this is no good because we don't
want that sort of thing happening over
here as well right
so they're there they're faced with
almost like you know sort of an alliance
or coalition of everybody else against
them it's really easy to get into this
we're on the right side of history we've
got to save the revolution we've gotta
gotta act now sort of mentality and I
think that turns deliberations about the
general will more into whoever is able
to to make the case at the time that
they're there representing the general
will they get to decide and and in the
revolution it like you know it's
slipping from one person's hands to the
next so like you could be the guy who's
on top this month but I'm gunning for
you and I find some way to show that
you're not a true revolutionary and now
you're gonna be beheaded and now I'm
going to be the general will guy for a
while I mean it's really not a very
practical notion I think it's very
powerful notion though and and there is
something really good behind it you know
it's it's supposed to be motivating us
to
act and set things up in accordance with
a common good not just not just our own
selfish interests but it's so easy to
it's a mistake our own interests or
something like them for the common good
isn't it you know especially when we
know we're doing it on the scale of a
nation that's another point I was going
to make to Rousseau didn't think that
his theories would work for France they
really wouldn't work that well for any
big country like that you need something
more like a Swiss canton a small place
where you can have a republic and
everybody knows each other and they can
you know it's it's not subject to so
much manipulation I don't think that he
thought his ideas would work for a place
like this either I mean if you think
about our politics even here at the
local level it's practically impossible
to meet all your constituents you know
well you know great example in Milwaukee
you know we have the mayor right so the
mayor is a very important figure and
then we have the county commissioner the
county commissioner he's not from here
he's actually from somewhere out east I
don't know
New Hampshire or Boston or something
like that christabella
he's just a manager type who happened to
have God himself you know over here and
made a case for why he should be elected
and he keeps getting elected what's that
yeah well that that certainly doesn't
hurt and from a resilient perspective
you know there's nothing surprising
about rich people spending their money
on getting political office because then
they can use that to enrich themselves I
don't know how to belly yes but but you
know he's from a Russo Ian's perspective
there's no no way he should be in charge
of Milwaukee County should be somebody
who's from Milwaukee
but even Milwaukee County it's it's too
big of an entity I mean think about how
many people live there we don't all know
each other even if we all got in the
same Facebook group it would just be a
calm
you couldn't read it right there'd be so
many different threads so you know
Rousseau's ideas are not all that
practical for big countries like ours
and and I don't think he would have
thought he probably would have liked the
French Revolution in some respects but I
don't think he would have been very
optimistic about it you know being able
to really enforce things but they did
try to put into effect some of his ideas
one of the things that he wanted to see
was a new educational system and they
decided public education is the way to
go and they look to a meal as sort of a
guidebook for that they drew the ire of
Mary Wollstonecraft because they wanted
the public education to be just for men
and domestic education for women which
meant basically depriving them of
depriving women of the rights of man
right after Wollstonecraft had written a
vindication of the rights of man
defending the revolution against Burke
she has to write a vindication of the
rights of women against the French
Revolution Education Ministry who are
you know drying on Rousseau and she
attacks Rousseau very heavily in that
work in part because we so had some
pretty what would you call him pretty
retrograde concepts of male-female
relationships and what women were
capable of so you know that there was
another sort of contradiction in his
life you know he becomes this romantic
figure again we're talking about these
these contradictions and in his life and
thought I don't think that when it comes
down to it you can actually take all of
Rousseau's ideas and cram them together
in one systematic whole that that
actually works there's there's gonna be
some junctures where you're like well
you got to pick this or you got to pick
this or reject them both
well that's a good that's a good
question
I mean yeah so there are there are
thinkers who who are like that where it
is a progression with Rousseau I don't
think you can I don't think you can
explain it away that way there there are
some sometimes even within the same work
you can be like this is an interesting
stuff but you you just it doesn't all
fit you know like the social contract I
think is one like that I think it's I
think it's because we're so he had a lot
of ideas that he's working with and in
in some respects he's a deeper thinker
than many of the other enlightenment
philosophers of the time but there's
something kind of undisciplined about
him well there were I mean there were a
lot of French people who were quite self
disciplined at the time
Rousseau just wasn't one of them you
know he wasn't disciplined in his love
life
it wasn't disciplined in his personal
life he's not all that disciplined in
his writings there's a lot of rhetoric
mixed in and it doesn't that really
doesn't need to be there in some places
that sometimes I think the tracks a bit
from you know you get cool phrases like
you know man everywhere is free men
everywhere it was born free but he is in
Chains right or you know sometimes you
have to be forced to be free but a lot
of times if you look at the rhetoric can
you pick it apart you know it's sort of
like pulling at you know those those
puzzles that are all these different
threads together and they at the end
it's you're like what the hell's here
you know the more substantive ideas are
better I'd say but even those you know
he's you know his notion that our
sentiments or our emotional life has
developed over time I think that's a
really great insight other thinkers you
know like Nietzsche coming after him
share similar insights and I think go
further than Rousseau
but Rousseau is still you know he's got
some great observations here and there
about that I mean what else is there to
say about his ideas and in particular I
mean I don't I don't have too much else
that I had planned to go over but I will
say this he gets from some places he
gets a really bad rap as being like a
because of the general will being a like
proto-fascist being a totalitarian and I
don't think that's that's deserved I
think was so if you were to look at like
you know 1930s fascism I don't think he
would say yes this is this is exactly
what I had in mind but I don't think he
actually offers us workable solutions in
the end I think it's more that he helps
us formulate problems which he then
doesn't doesn't completely solve but
he's probably more on track and
realistic about human nature than many
of the other enlightenment philosophers
were because he takes account of our are
bad or a corrupt side without without
necessarily bringing in you know
Christian notions of like original sin
or stuff like that he tries to explain
how it is that we could we could go bad
and I think that's something that we do
have to take into account if we want to
be realistic about about the situations
that we we find ourselves in right so
that that's all I've I've got but you
know do you have questions or other
things you want to kick around where do
you think he comes down politically no I
mean socialism can mean a lot of
different things if we mean something
like state control of the economy
directing economic enterprises to try to
realize a sort of general level of
well-being among citizens I think he
could get behind that but he'd be he'd
be one of the guys who like like
Solzhenitsyn who would be saying yeah
this sounds really great it's too bad
that a bunch of ruthless bastards always
seem to take it over you know and then
start throwing people in camps you know
but but you know is that worse than
having a king in charge who basically
runs things to the benefit of the court
and part you know it's part of the
middle class and exploits the peasantry
or I think he'd probably be more for
that but you know ideally ideally you'd
want to have like a small state and like
I said that where everybody knows
everybody you'd want people to be as
independent as possible so something
like closer like Jeffersonian yeoman
farmers you know where we all have our
little plot of land and we trade with
each other and stay out of each other's
business as much as possible but you
know walk to our city center every month
or so to debate and vote on stuff that's
that's what he sort of had in mind but I
mean where do you ever see that
happening other than a few places like
Swiss cantons that does actually happen
sometimes although even though keep
those can be corrupted yeah
like consolidate on the prot yet and
Prussia yeah yeah you know Milwaukee at
one time was a bunch of little
settlements and they were kind of like
city-states
and their I don't know if you know the
history of Milwaukee but some of them
would be actually getting into conflicts
with each other there was a war over
bridges and it was between what we now
call West town in East town and one of
them was June oval and the other one but
somebody else whose name is in the
streets they were named after the guys
and then there was like another
settlement further up and they got into
a they got into a shooting war all over
the bridges and and whether the bridges
were being used to direct commerce to
one side or the other side of the river
and at one point in time the people on
the the west side came over and
destroyed one of the bridges and then
this is all before Wisconsin became a
state you know and then you know they
retaliated and masoor tort of like we're
so Yin city-states it doesn't always
work out great because city-states will
get into rivalries with each other over
dumb stuff if you think about like
medieval towns they you know people from
one town over would just hate hate the
guts out of the people from the next
town over and every once in a while
would like go and go into their
territory with clubs and beat up some
people and then come back and beat him
up so I don't know that that Rousseau in
communities actually the way to go you
know he's certainly an interesting
figure you know and any fits you know he
fits into his time really well because
if you think about what was going on
there's all these proposals for how are
we gonna fix things because it's clear
that there's all these problems and
they're not being solved well and
conflicts and people are starving and so
there's all these different ideas about
you know how we should fix things and
some of them actually get tried and none
of them ever seem to really work out and
make people happy well that's pretty
resilient
you know maybe then the alternative is
maybe we should go back to savagery but
then that doesn't seem to work out too
great for me think about the the
condition of women in insanitary
terrible you know they're exploited this
is a point that Wolf's don't grab me
she's like Rousseau you're too quick to
like dismiss civilization were naturally
civilized yet because women are still
being forced into all these subservient
positions you know so that even like the
you know the guy who really doesn't have
much to offer can at least think he's
better than women true civilization
hasn't actually been been reached yet so
who are you or so to complain about it
you know you're you're jumping the gun
instead of going back to savagery so
yeah I remember so somebody who's kind
of hard to bring to a good conclusion I
think so do you have any other questions
comments
[Music]